hey was geht ab jetzt bekommen zu einem
neuen video heute teil nummer 3 auf
jeden fall haben wir den kader dabei
letzte folge ist und damals gesagt
machen wir direkt einfach doch die
nächst folgende let's go wir wollen gar
nicht lange lagern von direct machen
hamburg wo haben wir den man unsere
unterlagen okay war das machen wir
gemacht wenn ich mal mit dem das hören
wir doch mal warum wir dieses wochenende
nicht mal so was richtig richtig schönes
machen weil ich ja gut da wieder drauf
guckt immer unser erste sportuhren finde
ich auch da war es noch ein bisschen
zusammen und ich mein erstes auto damals
noch dünner zwei wochen ich meine wir
bieten das von den vier monaten aus
wieder wenn ich mit ihr zusammen
das war ganz spontan ein du darfst meine
augen schminken wer sich nicht schon
wieder aus der das auch so
wer jetzt nicht voll geschminkt aus
sieht man dass das finde ich ja noch
mehr müde warte ich habe noch eine frage
deine füße sind zwei städte vor dort ist
dann einfach die füße
würdest du dann socken tragen warum
trägst mbh stellt die frau jetzt ist das
auge noch ne und den auch noch dann ist
das doch noch das stellen wir lieber
wieder weg keine widerrede das nächste
das ist so beim gucken ob ich es gut
rüberbringen können
du willst doch abnehmen oder kleiner
tipp schminktisch nicht ganz so viel da
bist du direkt fünf kilo leichter davon
sie beraten die auf die werden zu üben
mach mal ins gesicht
vielleicht jetzt gucke ja normal
ja ist gut wir sind jetzt schon zwei
jahre zusammen
wann hast du noch mal geburtstag
aber das sind wohl viele mädchen
schlimmsten das macht das video ist
impression ja bisschen complicated auf
jeden fall 24 kommt auch locker
irgendwann raus aber ihr könnt jetzt und
in die kommentare schreiben so eurer
meinung nach was man halt niemals zu
seiner freundin sagen sollte lese ich
mir das alles durch und dann später hier
in der nächsten folge all diese sachen
an den kopf und wenn es euch gefallen
hat könnt ihr gerne auch nach oben gibt
sie hat jetzt auch ein youtube channel
der ist in der video beschreibung vor
allem könnt ihr gerne abonnieren also
vorbeischauen da und wir sehen uns dann
am nächsten musst du wissen man training
wieder ein video mit ihr
wir sehen uns mittwoch wieder leute die
euch alle ganz toll ich hab mir gereicht